All right. I'm going to show you video here of
an adult. This is a. All grown human Republican
Congressman Chip Roy from Texas, throwing a
tantrum, the likes of which you would expect
from a two year old in a sandbox, about what?
About mask wearing, given the new guidance from
the CDC about the spread of the Delta variant,
in great part because of unvaccinated people, the
House of Representatives is looking at reimposing
a mask requirement on the floor of the House. And
in fact, I believe they have done it. There are
some members that are protesting at one such
member is Roy. You will notice if you're watching
that like a toddler, Marjorie Taylor Green. This
is such an attention seeking behavior in Asby.
I know a lot of people who participate in these
attention seeking behavior behaviors. You know who
I'm talking about? It's you go to a restaurant and
there's someone at the next table over talking
really, really loudly about how much money they
make or how smart they are or the vacation they
went on, not for the benefit of the people at
their table, but the for the benefit of the people
at surrounding tables. It's an attention seeking
behavior. Marjorie Taylor Green does this all the
time on the House floor when when the debate is
about masks or vaccines or abortion or whatever,
she plants herself right behind the person who is
speaking and ranting that's going on here. Let's
listen to Chip Roy. Absolutely lose his mind.
This is not a two year old folk folks. Take a look
Speaker 2: here on the people's house. We got to
go around and see, OK, we can't come to the floor.
I can't excuse my constitutional duty unless I
wear a mask, which isn't vaccines or masks.
Speaker 1: Does he not understand it or is
he pretending not to understand it?
Speaker 2: The vaccines work or they
don't work. Do the math works or they
don't work. I'd like to know which it is.
I'd like Dr. Valge to come down and answer
a single question about natural immunity.
Speaker 1: And then you, Margery Taylor
Green, nodding like Chip Roy is making
some kind of incredibly salient point here,
Speaker 2: infected with the virus. Do you
have immunity or are they just going to go around
poking people saying you must take a vaccine? Oh,
but sorry, the vaccine doesn't work. You
must wear a mask. This institution is a sham
and we should adjourn and shut this place down.
Speaker 1: And so there a Marjorie Taylor Greene
standing up and cheering and clapping and so on.
So this was the point. They wanted to adjourn
the House proceedings over the mask guidelines.
I mean, it's sort of like the congressional
equivalent of if I can't play in the sandbox, I'm
going to poop in it so nobody else can either.
Write apologies for the I'm still thinking of that
pastor playing with the dog poop yesterday. And
then we move on to Kevin McCarthy. Kevin McCarthy.
Mark McCarthy is the House minority leader. And it
gives me great pleasure to call him the minority
leader because Republicans did lose control of
the House. And he goes on a rant about all the
things he claims Democrats want to control. I
don't even know where he's getting this stuff,
Speaker 3: but it's just like their philosophy.
They want a mandate. They want to
impose. They want to tell you when
you can go to school, when you can
Speaker 1: eat, when you can eat
that. Does anybody know what that's about? Is
that about like lunchtimes at school? Is there
actually something he's referring to or is that
just more trash gutter trash from these people?
Speaker 3: You know what they're going to do
if you walk into this building without a mask,
they're going to charge you five hundred dollars.
Why? Because they got the power to do it.
Speaker 1: How ominous. What an ominous thing.
Now, there was one guy and I just absolutely love
this. There was one guy who wasn't having
any of this garbage, and it's our friend,
Tim Ryan. Tim Ryan has been a guest on the
show. Really interesting guy. You know,
you don't have to agree with him on every single
policy, but just, you know, he's an informed guy.
He has interests. He's intellectually
curious. He knows about mindfulness.
He knows about alternative energy. He's just a
good guy delivering an impassioned takedown of
these absurd Republicans. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Somebody represents the hot spots,
right? And they get on a plane and they fly
here and they interact with all of us. And then
we leave here and we go home to our families.
Some take care of their sick parents. Some take
care of kids who may have an autoimmune
disorder. And I just find it absolutely
immature and appalling to somehow diminish
it, to try to score cheap political points,
right? That's exactly what we saw a few minutes
ago. Well, yeah, that is beneath a minority
leader of one of the major political parties.
Speaker 1: In the end, it's sort of not any
more. In other words, Trump pianism has reduced
the dialog so much that it's actually no longer
beneath the Republican Party to do what
they did earlier ited states of America,
Speaker 3: saying we should take no caution. Oh,
that someone from a hot spot, hot spot is working
in this chamber and could potentially get someone
infected that could go home to a sick parent
or are immune compromised kid. That is beneath
us. That is beneath us and it's certainly
beneath leadership here in Washington, D.C.,
Speaker 1: it should be, but unfortunately
it is just par for the course. Now, this is how
Trump in politics works. Kevin McCarthy is a
absolutely perfect example of that. So an
absolute mess on the House floor. And these
people and by the way, many of these people
are vaccinated, even though they talk about,
oh, mandatory jabs and they're vaccinated,
they're back. But if they were to just say it,
they would suffer politically. That's the
reality. And so many of them are hiding
their own vaccination will actually
get back to that a little bit later.